it's all fake news man let me let me
show you this i want to prove to you
guys
this is the best thing right here check
out the story from the new york times
donald trump's tax returns
the times obtained donald trump's tax
information extending over more than two
decades
revealing struggling properties vast
write-offs and an audit battle
and hundreds of millions of dollar
millions in debt coming due
take a look at this first these first
two sentences donald j
trump paid 750 in federal income tax the
year he won the presidency
in his first year in the white house he
paid another 750.
you know what's really funny about that
they debunk themselves
in their own story this is not true he
did not
so let's let's be fair
you guys ever watch rick and morty yeah
have you seen the one
uh so there's an episode where they're
on the uh on the spaceship in the
simulation
and the teacher asks morty what's like i
think he said what's nine times eight
and morty goes it's at least 40 and he
goes that's
correct it is at least 40. like
it's true so when they say donald trump
paid 750 in federal income taxes
that means he did at least 750. yeah at
least seven
so it's like if if something cost you
100 bucks and you spent 10 dollars i
could say you spent ten dollars yeah you
spent more than ten dollars but you did
give them ten dollars right
the new york times actually says in
their own story i gotta i gotta
scroll down to try and figure out where
it is that trump paid
way more than that and let the
government just keep it
yet they open their story by saying he
only paid
uh seven seven hundred and fifty dollars
i am scrolling down this is a really
long story actually can you just press
ctrl f and then four point two
i'm anxiously awaiting these new york
times reporters having to take refuge in
embassy 4.2 for accepting stolen
material
that's true julian assange style check
this out
each time he requested an extension to
file his 1040 and each time he made the
required payments to the
irs for income taxes he might owe 1
million dollars for 2016 and 4.2 for
2017
but virtually all of that liability was
washed away when he eventually filed
and most of the payments were rolled
forward to cover potential taxes
in future years you that means it means
he gave the government 5.2 million
dollars even though he
lost a ton of money and only owed 1500.
so when they say he paid 750 that's just
100
right he only owed but that's not
sensational
that wouldn't that wouldn't catch
people's attention and now every
headline is new york times report trump
only paid 700
to lie he paid more than they did it's
in their own story that he paid
4.2 million horrific journalism it's not
journalism
it's propaganda and this story is the
same story they wrote in 2016.
it's the same thing i hope you guys are
ready for the october surprises because
it's going to be
it's going to be fun dude there's
debates tomorrow
no it isn't i don't believe it it's
coming i don't believe it joe will not
miss it
it's all he's got what's he going to do
stumble over his words you know what
he's going to do
at 9 52 tomorrow morning he's going to
say i'm calling a lid
i'm not making any appearances today and
then he's just not going to appear
he's not going to elaborate at all in
debate i just can't yeah they're going
to be
like uh are you coming to the debate no
we're supposed to go he's got an ego
he thinks he can do it he's going to
smile into the camera and go come on man
come on man come on
man he's getting ready to go dude
they're gonna rig it that's what i think
who's here i really had the debate
questions for weeks they did it in 2016
and nobody's bringing it up now
so good point but but it doesn't matter
who's moderating
uh who's the first one he's the first
moderator they don't you know they don't
understand
when you see these stories about taxes
they still haven't figured out why
people voted for trump
because donald trump is a dude carrying
a giant torch
and just lighting the establishment on
fire people don't care if he's covered
in human feces and is swearing while he
does it
they just want him to bring the flames
so i'm like don what
was it what was it in the 2016 election
trump's like i i'm a smart businessman i
paid no taxes
and everyone cheered and they think the
story is bad
they're they're saying one of the
stories i read they were like i think
it's in here
they're they're saying many republicans
whatever trump assuming he was a savvy
businessman
yeah it's like isn't he if he paid no
taxes and he's a billionaire
yeah and they're also like being like
look he's broke he's broke how terrible
but also
being like he's a billionaire and you
guys are supporting this billionaire and
i'm like wait which one are we supposed
to be mad at
like big and jews yeah either they're
not seeing what sticks just throwing
everything
they're saying everything and that's the
problem there's no leadership it's all
over the
place so you've got donald trump is a
billionaire who won't pay his taxes
then you've got donald trump as a
failure who is losing so much money
that he doesn't pay taxes which one is
it he's both he's a billionaire
and he's running a deficit every year so
he doesn't have to pay taxes by
overspending no no no no no that's a
back into his company that's a not b
a you can choose a or b but so there on
paper he doesn't he's losing money so
they call him
poor but he's not he actually owns a
billion dollars of assets
here's the point if trump is choosing to
write down his assets to save money
that's that's the first option it is
second option is trump is a failure and
his
businesses are collapsing they're losing
money both but that doesn't make them a
failure
no that's not what they say though like
like the the young turks dude tweeted
out
straight up trump is a failure his
businesses are collapsing he's all these
bankruptcies did you say he had like
five bankruptcies out of his hundred
companies or something
trump trump i don't know how i think it
was like five bankruptcies out of like
500 plus businesses
that's incredible that's a great number
and the other thing too is dude this is
ev this is so annoying this is
everything they did
in in 2015 and 16 like trump water went
out of business and
trump stakes don't exist in trump
magazine go to darrell go to trump doral
guess what
there'll be a trump water bottle on the
nightstand you can order a trump steak
and trump magazine is right there on the
coffee table
it's not that they went out of business
it's that they're for his properties
but they just lie about everything
it's it's just lies and so then when you
see like project veritas
and they say no james o'keefe is lying
i'm like dude i don't believe you
it's kind of like if trump was a movie
that was really good
the the democrats are trying to make
another movie that's better but they're
have they have worse actors and bad
directing and it's just worse and
you can't tell people that that movie is
better you can't like
no amount of commercials is gonna make
that movie better because it's crappier
so now they're trying to tell us and
show us how it's better it's better but
like every time you look at the movie
you know
it's horrible compared to that other
movie the other movie's awesome compared
to that people are entertained by trump
yes
superiorly he's hilarious he's an actor
he's got a hit show
trump keeps demanding joe biden take a
drug test i just love it it's hilarious
dude i i can understand when people
complain about decorum and things like
that like the highest office
but i'm sitting back like you know what
the crony establishment
has been playing dirty politics for
forever
as long as i've been alive i have no
faith in these people to do the right
thing
everybody screams war is bad and then
they go okay vote for me and i'll end
the war and then as soon as you elect
them they go
and then press the nuke button and so
i'm just like i'm out when trump comes
in
and he's running around screaming and
he's like throwing flaming torches at
the establishment i'm just like you want
to get mad
dude you guys have been ripping us off
forever as long as i've been alive it's
been
it's been a dirty game it's been all
fake and now finally some dude comes in
and he's messing up your business and
you're coming to me and crying about it
i don't care don't forget jimmy carter
didn't take us in any wars in the media
he hated that guy
they ripped it they made him out to be
the worst president of all time
trump should just do like a press
conference where he's like if i get
reelected
i will fire 15 nukes at the middle east
and they're all going to cheer and be
like
donald trump is is a hero oh we should
re-elect him
no the new thing is over the top they
cheered for him when he was talking
or when he did bomb right right right
like this is the greatest thing he's
ever done he's finally a president now
and i'm like so they want
why do they want that though that's so
weird it's because i think the
military-industrial complex conversation
is too
um simplistic like they're it's it's not
it's not just about making money well
war is good for ratings
yeah that's true oh yeah it drives
netflix yeah
but you know i wonder you know what i
think
you know it's better for writings than
war what trump
yeah trump is the best they found a guy
who is literally a tv personality and
they were like
this is cash money baby you see tucker
carlson's ratings
almost 5 million it's like the biggest
ratings in cable history
for cable news history that's crazy
these news come these tv companies
supposed to be collapsing
no tucker carlson is basically like
walking through the fog of fake news of
the machete clearing the way and people
are following behind him
and then you get the mainstream and the
progressive saying he's like he's far
right
he's he's all right all these other
ridiculous stupid things that are just
ridiculously not true you know
the craziest thing though is he's the
one who has on
like anti-war leftists i know you're
never going to see people from like the
gray zone or tulsi gabbard on
like msnbc or cnn but tucker will have
them on
and he'll have a completely like
respectful
intelligent conversation with them
nobody else does it
it's funny i love it it's funny when he
tries to have a conversation with
these like ultra woke you know culty
people
who just don't speak it's like it's like
trying to talk to one of the stepford
wives
you know like they're actually robots
they were robots right is that that
movie was about yeah they were all
replayed other one or you know you know
i've never seen it
it's like it's like a great movie what
is it like it's like it's like a 50s
style neighborhood of like perfect
housewives but they're all just replaced
by robots because the husbands wanted
surfing and watch them yeah i remember
tucker had on this woman
and he like asked her an honest question
and then she just goes into robo mode
and she's like
tucker you're all far right and it's
like
what you can't you can't have
conversations man
you know infamous one with the teen
vogue lady that's probably the one i
think that's one
thing yeah yeah yeah oh jeez you know
what you know
i understand there are trump supporters
that are zealots
that are like die hard maga you can't
tell them anything you know they won't
believe it
but it's like cnn did this thing where
they went to a trump rally
started talking to trump supporters and
trump supporters started you know you
know making fun of joe biden
and then when the trump when when the uh
cnn reporter handed the phone to the guy
to show them that this one video of
biden sleeping was fake the guy went
i must have missed that one but you know
i've seen a lot more other things
you can't do that with antifa you can do
that with progressives
so what cnn showed me there i was like
wow that was actually really reasonable
the guy is embarrassing that that he
believed fake news
but he looked at it and went uh i must
have missed that one
that's great right that show that shows
that he's thinking like when he said i'm
gonna beat joe biden he actually said
i'm gonna be
joe biden yeah if you look at the full
concept of the video he said i'm gonna
be joe biden
he was he was like so this is a viral
clip where people said joe biden said
he's gonna beat joe biden
but he's someone he gets asked something
about his record they're like what's
your record gonna be
as president he goes look people keep
asking me what i'm going to do but i'm
joe biden
and i'm going to be joe biden and i'm
like i get what he's saying
but i guess some people heard the the t
i guess it's because we don't enunciate
our t's and you know the way we speak in
colloquial english
neither of these guys are saints neither
of them are demons
i mean biden's got good qualities really
creeps me out i don't think biden has
good qualities he's got some
no wait he's not like he's not a demon
possessed by satan or anything he's just
a terrible presidential candidate his
face looks like a purge mask
that's just mean i think he got a bunch
of botox or something in the last five
and so years hillary man it's tripping
me out yeah remember what she used to
look at before her cheek lifts what's
that they give me the heebie gb
remember when that weird like fake
hillary picture came out
there was a picture with hillary and
bill clinton people were like that's not
hillary that's like what is that
it's like a body double or something oh
yeah i vaguely remember it and it really
really didn't look like her and people
were saying it's not and then i recall
when they were saying that kim jong-un
was dead
and then the photos emerged and everyone
started saying it's not really him and
the media called him conspiracy
theorists
and then it turned out it wasn't really
him i had a question about that so
remember when donald trump tweeted out a
couple weeks ago
kim jong-un is alive and well he's doing
great he's better than ever
what was up with that why didn't he do
that out of nowhere
i don't know why not because they think
that kim jong-un has been
gone for a while no i thought they
confirmed that he was actually alive how
did they confirm that with pre-recorded
video
i have no idea no not necessarily a
story that i am following all too much
but uh but but anyway joe biden i think
is not good
joe biden his whole career what has he
done
it's been plastic garbled you know
whatever he's got to say to get the keys
to the castle i'll tell you this man
you have to be a special kind of insane
to be like well this guy's been in
office for 47 years and nothing's
improved i think i'll try that again
no he's terr i gave him a 17 out of 100
as a presidential candidate quality but
if he was in your house
he wouldn't rob you he wouldn't beat you
up that's not true no he didn't just sit
there he'd probably he might be a jerk
but then he'd uh
you know eat and then he'd leave there
was a story which judicial watch
confirmed that i had wrote about in 2017
i knew some secret service guys
they told me a story about how bited
would always like
grope women and girlfriends as secret
service agents at the christmas party to
the point where they had to cancel the
christmas party that they had
and one of the agents actually like
wound up like ready to hit him
and he ended up getting suspended
because he was going to hit the vice
president so
what judicial watch found is that they
they issued a request for the documents
and then the confirmation they got was
that those documents have since been
deleted
and they were like so those documents
existed oh that's how they confirmed it
yeah but it
he strikes me as like see trump i think
can be kind of like
snarky and ha and you know kind of
arrogant almost but he's not mean and i
don't
think he's but i don't think he's mean
like i don't think he would ever be like
mean to somebody
biden like when he snaps at people like
he seems
did you see him call the military yeah a
bunch of stupid bastards
yeah and that was the one where he was
yelling at the guy saying like
he probably oh that's why she's your ex
or something yeah yeah
or his voters look fat yeah or the the
the dude uh who was asking the questions
and he go and then he's like why why why
why why why he grabs the guy yeah like i
don't think trump's mean like that i
think that by
me trump is mean if you're mean to trump
yeah trump will be mean if you're mean
to him that's it
if you're nice to trump trump will be he
loves it he loves the positive attention
i'm not the only one who's pointed this
out the left doesn't want to accept it
that if the democrats
just played to trump's ego he'd have
compromised on everything he would have
been like okay
look at the gun control thing was it
like he the bum stock ban yeah
they started saying we want to do this
and he was like oh it's winning me
favors i like this they're saying good
things about me and then a bunch of
conservatives were like what's he doing
the democrats needed to realize trump
likes it when you're nice to him and
he'll be nice back
then they decided you know what let's
just insult him in every possible way
so trump is just like screw you guys
yeah he like cut his losses
you know it got to a certain point where
he realized they hate him so much
there's no point
and that's that's that's a really dumb
thing to do if you want something
then even even if you think that this
side's not going to give it
or it's hard to do you don't win by
insulting attacking them
it's not gonna you're not gonna get
anything then what happens is the
american people get tired of it
they vote republican now republicans are
gonna get three supreme court
justices and they have that the house
they have the senate
they're the senate they have the
president we'll see what happens man i'm
really interested because
you know i don't you know money talks
and if lindsey graham really is
down because after ruth better ginsburg
died democrats got you know lit on fire
i mean that figuratively like they got
motivated then maybe he'll lose
and i wouldn't be surprised because i'm
seeing a lot of trump supporters don't
like him either i would love to see him
i don't like him
yeah he doesn't do anything no neither
is mitch mcconnell man let him go
yeah i don't i need term limits i don't
like any of the establishment
like whenever i think about who i
possibly like i just think about the
eight republicans and the three
democrats who agree with trump on
withdrawing from the middle east
i'm like everybody else i don't know
what you're doing but you know a couple
of the democrats are
who voted for that i can respect that
and give him credit for it absolute
respect
for for doing the right thing but some
of these other democrats have done
really dumb things too
yeah i mean i get it the republicans
have as well but
you know like matt gates um who else was
in the house who did this um
i can't remember i know it was uh matt
gates probably thomas massey
i think he's in the house right yeah
yeah yeah thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you